guys before the video starts i'm trying
to raise three hundred thousand meals
for one thousand families in pakistan
yemen somalia bangladesh born sisters in
charlotte help us feed them this ramadan
to open and break their fast
[Music]
so guys before i start the video i want
to share this with you brown sisters
anybody that wants to learn the quran
and i was in that position a couple of
years ago brothers and sisters and it is
a struggle sometimes but to have a
manual
like this which is easy to use colorful
not only that brothers and sisters it
has a step-by-step guide to so much so
it has diagrams it shows you images of
where you can pronounce
each letter from teachers and students
have called it the most unique gaiden on
the market
so guys welcome to this video now you'll
be asking brother ali this is the third
video you're doing on trunks we know
free
sunnah but you know there's a lane you
stop why are you doing are you trying to
get attention you know that you want to
get chunks attention or what is it
well probably the first one i did was
about the advan the thing that going off
his phone to remind him of salah
second one was with the transgender
which he was a little bit uncomfortable
i still found that
amazing you know and thirdly this now
why this and in ramadan
brothers and sisters yeah why are you
obsessed with them no no there's a point
i'm obsessed i'm obsessed
because i can see some goodness in the
brother when i see goodness in the
brother
and a lot of people follow him i have to
use that and talk to him inshallah you
just want clout in it
listen he was not meant to say that
that's something me and you we spoke
about this
okay i'm stuck in here now yeah so yeah
that's you know what
people actually say that but the reason
why we will mention people like chunks
or whatnot is because
unfortunately it's it's an unfortunate
state that the um is in
that we don't uh look towards the the
scholars and the people of knowledge
as our role models i mean just look at
the amount of views these people will
get a lot of views
uh that our youngsters will be
gravitated towards them
and it's unfortunate that they don't get
that much
attached to their religion so when they
see that their quote-unquote role models
do this
it's a very good opportunity for us to
kind of highlight that
and highlight the lessons that they may
not have received
otherwise from the people that they
don't necessarily go towards or all them
are the people of knowledge
so it's that's that's why we talk and
that's why we look for these
opportunities so we can get islam to the
people that need islam
exactly and not only that for example
the prophet peace be upon him would give
dawa to the people of influence yeah if
he's a person of influence
do you force him well that's where i'm
going to be where am i supposed to be
you know what i'm saying
no long term is a chunk now there's two
things that i came across the first well
this is the first thing that i came
across
and right after this bro
okay okay so one second
so the first thing i came across was i
was just going through instagram as you
can see
um on my screen here and i came across
this then i went to a story and
you you'll be shocked what i found here
okay yeah i want to say let me practice
my shocked face okay
no no a bit make a bit more like of your
eyes open
you've been ideologically molested yes
you're ready here we go
okay now that's what i'm talking about
bro
now let's go to today's scene let's just
read it so what he recited was
with the name of allah the most merciful
the very merciful uh yeah
seen by the quran that is full of wisdom
you are truly one of the messengers of
allah
and you are on the straight path yeah i
think it stopped there this quran being
a revelation from the almighty
the very merciful so that you may warn
people whose fathers were not warned and
hence they were unaware
the word has indeed come true about most
of them so they will not believe
and it goes on yeah but now why did this
i saw that and i thought let me go to
the story and find the
full station but when i went to his
story as you can see he's got the quran
last 10 days get it in my muslim people
then yeah
okay now that to me bro it's powerful
now let me tell you why it's powerful
and why it's so important why is it
powerful
let me tell you why yeah because you
know why we're in the powerful nights
the last 10 nights
yes the night of power as well okay all
right surprise brothers and sisters so
when you go home you make it so you take
a shower and head to the masjid to catch
the night of power
and let me tell you why it's powerful
yeah now some people we look at chunks
yeah
and we know he's not perfect like many
people yeah i'm not perfect he's not
perfect
if he watches this video we're not like
saying that you know we're picking on
someone that
what we're seeing is that he has his
short thoughts and he knows that in the
public domain he might make some errors
you know subhanallah
but what's really important and key is
this following yeah
where praise is jew we give that praise
yeah okay
now i'm not saying i'm i'm saying that
god i'm promoting trunks and this
i'm not saying that jake i'm trying to
say what i'm trying to say is bro and
sisters yeah
especially in ramadan look you can sin
in life you can
be involved in riba there are people who
might be listening to this which they
bought a house in riba reba is waging
war against allah
interest israel is waging war against
allah okay
you might be committing sinner okay
there are some people who are committing
zina in ramadan
in ramadan and committing okay you might
be drinking
alco whatever you're doing now whatever
is seen
you're doing brother sisters yeah what's
important i'm not trying to say i'm not
trying to categorize brother trunks into
this i'm not saying i'm trying to give a
general reminder so i don't want people
to get twisted in that yeah
but aki one of the biggest ways shaitan
attacks you
is he says look you're drinking alco
you're involved in riba
you're just committing zinna yeah or
you're committing theft
or you have violated the rights of
another believer whatever it may be
yeah okay you are now going to go and
praise allah
and now what a lot of us think and tell
me if i'm not worthy to pray
no you're not worthy and you shouldn't
and then he comes and says you know what
look
you start praying once you fix yourself
yeah now you're not you're not worthy
yeah
now what i like about trunks is that he
might be in a specific field in the
industry
maybe music or whatever it may be but
one thing that you have to give to him
and this is the default
position if you are sinning that we all
should be in
the same goes with me is that no matter
what sins you commit
yeah you should never ever think oh no i
committed zinna
ah you know i come in dinner every night
i drink alcohol every night i
uh involved in liber continuously i uh
steal from people
i violate the rights of other people
some people like that some long lists
exactly but you should never
ever yeah that was a long question you
should never ever think to yourself
uh i shouldn't play sallah never your
default position b
should be what and tell me am i wrong
shouldn't you do for position b
i'm still going gonna always pray masala
when it's ramadan i am gonna fast the
last ten nights like brother chang said
quran you build your arrest uh
connection with the quran
sadaqah i'm gonna give sadaqah my zakah
okay a lot of people of us do we
calculate
how much is jew and okay do you not
think that that is the default position
we should all be in
and that's what i take from that bro
when i see trunks when i see his quran
resolution it was a beautiful recitation
and when he's doing a reminder yeah and
his video where he did about for example
the event going off
him being a bit uncomfortable in this
i'm trying to say okay that shows me
iman and that shows me
that he's not letting that lifestyle
overtake
thing is is very good point you said
each sinful act
yes carries its own penalty yes so if
you
the the long list that you said dealing
with ribba you get sin
for that yes but if because of that
you're like i'm not going to pray
because i'm not ready to pray
you get another sin for not praying yes
but if for example you've done something
music or something and then now you've
prayed
that means you've got your prayer of
course the prophet
said if you do a bad deed replace it
with a good deed exactly
exactly now of course you do need to
make tawban you didn't need to reform
and that dolby needs to be done properly
but yeah i don't i think the key message
here is
that don't stop the little bit of
light that you have yeah because all it
takes look when you're lost in a tunnel
all it takes is a couple of rays of
light yep even if they're
at a distance those yeah it gives you
hope and you know which direction to go
in
it might take you long it might take you
you know
you know a very difficult journey but
eventually you know that that's the
direction you need to be heading that's
a beautiful
amazing analogy brother sisters and
that's how it needs to be because
you know with the quran salah you need
to understand you might be sinning yeah
look you're sinning but one of the
things is allah says never to despair
his mercy
yeah never ever this is mercy and you
don't know the quran you read the salah
you've been continuously reading still
no matter your sinning the riba that
you're involved in
whatever it may be sorry the the quran
the salah the sadhaka
zaka kindness you do not know from what
angle
allah is going to say the sadhaka that
you gave or the quran that you read or
the salah you've been continuously given
because allah says salah keeps you away
from
evilness yeah you don't know which one
of them is going to be a door
that's going to cause you to stop the
river stop the sinner stop the alcohol
stop the theft
and stop the other sins bro and sisters
so that's the reason why
i find it admirable in that sense that
trunks or anyone else it may be
there might be an industry might be
music it might be whatever it may be
that they are still when it's ramadan
brother i'm fasting
yeah it'll be outside ramadan i'm still
praying and i will pray yeah
okay avoiding haram foods yeah
because what that show is actually
that's the sign there's iman there you
go i'm trying to say
and that is how we all need to be and
that's the reason why i hope it's kind
of my third and final video
but i genuinely when i see these things
it really does bring
ease to one's heart you know i'm trying
to say because there's many youtubers
out there and aki
at the end of the day we don't know
where we're going to be i'm trying to
say allah protect us
but the thing is brothers and sisters is
that no matter what youtuber is and
do not ever look at these people and
while i i try to implement this myself
here i've advised many people and
because i'm the one advising people
think
i'm coming from a place of purity
because i'm advising i'm not being
advised yeah
yeah whoever advised i don't need to
give names yeah
wallahi genuinely i try to make a
principle principle to myself
that i never ever think i'm better than
that person
i never ever think because i always say
to myself
ali that person while is there a chance
that he can
he can change a new change for the worse
100 yeah 100 percent bro that's a
possibility
that exists as long as that possibility
exists actually there is no way i can
look at the person i'm advising
and think i'm better than them
impossible if um
i'll end on this he was one of the ten
promised
jannah yeah what happened when the names
of the
african came down they don't what do you
want to want to say yeah
i don't know what did you might do you
immediately assumed that
his name was in the list of monavie and
what did he do did he just sit down what
did he do he was
he went and he asked
was the secret keeper of the prophet
that look i'm not going to ask you
who's on the list right just tell me
it's my name from the list
bro i'm getting well i'm getting shivers
can you imagine you're the 10 tempest
jannah you're running
to a sahabi yeah and you tell him
is my name on it but there's a reason
why
every every salah we say
guide us to the straight path and even
in iman
which means to alternate because at the
heart alternates our iman fluctuates
like the feather at the bottom of a tree
the wind comes
it flips it the wind comes it flips it
so our iman
does fluctuate the thing is some people
watching they might say look i do tawba
but then i fall in that sin again
one million times one minute yeah
because the thing is to you
think that the analogy is like this that
a person they're standing they fall over
then they get back up again then they
fall over then they get back up again
to a casual observer it seems like this
person doesn't want to stay full and
this person even
wants to get up yes but a person that
gets tripped up and they stay on the
floor oh no
i'm on the floor what do i do i'm just
going to stay like this
yeah you're not going to move in life so
allah sees it like this
look as long as there is a breath in
your body keep asking for forgiveness
the prophet sallam would
ask for forgiveness 80 to 100 times a
day yeah yeah
this is the this is the the forget the
people that have been given glad tidings
this is the message of allah yeah this
is the best man to walk earth
and like prophet muhammed said brother
sisters and we'll end on this
is that he said don't ever think to
yourself that once i stop
sinning i will start reading the quran
once i stop sinning i will praise allah
once i stop sinning i was no no
he says the quran and the salah that you
do is what's going to cause you to stop
sin
don't think of it logically comes to you
with a logic yeah
like adrian said they asked him he said
why do you wipe on top of our feet but
not underneath
he said islam is not then if it was a
matter of logic you were underneath
unbelievable
exactly but islam is not just about
logic
yeah we believe in a metaphysical world
it's your quran
one day might come and wallahi you'd
become a new person
promises that was it inshallah and may
allah bless you guys inshallah i'm
trying to raise three hundred thousand
meals
uh and we've nearly reached our target
the link is in the description box below
and do not forget to order this for your
loved ones this ramadan for eid
a brilliant eid gift only 10 pounds i'm
getting one myself
you said you said free but no we need to
support causes
and muslim businesses brothers and
sisters yeah and none of us are getting
a cut
from promoting this yes the the scholar
that has made this
yeah masha'allah you know a lot of love
and respect for him
if you said it brother that's it we
don't need here anymore yeah okay
i had